[Música]
vamos ahora a nuestra revista de prensa
con Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela y el tema que nos
trae aquí el día de hoy tiene que ver
con la Guerra de Ucrania abrimos con la
prensa local que sigue reportando ese
minuto a minuto sobre la situación en la
ciudad de bagmud en el este del país las
tropas rusas avanzan pero Ucrania
todavía resiste hay un artículo de kiev
poste que usted nos va a mostrar sí
Ángela vamos a empezar con el kievs que
dice que aunque Moscú pueda seguir
avanzando en algunas de las partes de
Bach mood Ucrania todavía resiste y
repele importantes ataques Según
analistas consultados por este medio en
las últimas horas concretamente en el
último fin de semana Rusia Ha logrado
avances limitados obteniendo eso sí una
ventaja posicional según el Instituto
para el estudio de la guerra con sede en
Washington Rusia está preparando un
movimiento de giro que obligaría al
enemigo a abandonar las posiciones sin
que supusiera un cerco a toda la ciudad
de bahamut en estos momentos según el
Instituto para el estudio de la guerra
se dan las condiciones para una retirada
controlada de las tropas ucranianas sin
que queden totalmente rodeados según el
kiev post por el momento las maniobras
defensivas por parte de Ucrania
continúan y en las últimas horas han
repetido al menos 130 ataques no solo en
bahmud sino en otras urbes como cupiansk
o Lima otros analistas consultados por
el kit post consideran que Ucrania no
está en estos momentos ante la decisión
inminente de protagonizar una retirada
de tropas en la ciudad pase lo que pase
en bajo muchos tiene el post al final
Ucrania ha avanzado con esos ataques
todavía reteniendo esa ofensiva rusa y
el kremlin ha utilizado esta ciudad poco
estratégica para dejarse miles de tropas
en el terreno
en la prensa rusa también están
presentes Marta las últimas noticias de
la ofensiva del kremlin y vamos a
destacar un reportaje en el frente de
uno de los medios más afines al gobierno
si Ángela nos referimos al Cosmos of
kaya Prada cuando es su corresponsal en
el terreno Alexander cots hace este fin
de semana un reportaje en el terreno
desde la propia ciudad de bahamut dice
este medio que allí la gente está muy
contenta con las tropas rusas que los
besan y los bautizan después de sentirse
liberados de las tropas ucranianas hace
este periodista una crónica desde el
terreno y sobre cómo las tropas rusas
están poco a poco consiguiendo mayores
facciones de terreno en bahamut y en los
alrededores de esta urbe del donbas las
propias rusas tropas rusas tienen que
realizar parte de sus operaciones a pies
sostiene este periodista en terreno
porque las vías están muy afectadas
incluso tienen que dotar de agua o de al
ejército Pues eso caminando porque no se
puede hacer de otra manera en estos
momentos las tropas rusas estarían
liberando a los civiles que permanecen
en esos búnkers en esos sótanos y estas
personas esta población civilés estarían
mostrando afecto y agradecimiento por
haberles liberado de los ucranianos una
cita textual del periodista dice que sin
respeto por sus Defensores uno puede ver
de inmediato a quienes consideran los
suyos esto la población civil según este
medio quiebre estaría perdiendo entre
500 tropas al día entre muertos y
heridos en el frente en bahamut y
también refleja este artículo del Cosmos
que haya Prada una cita de uno de los
comandantes de Wagner que dice que
Ucrania está intentando volar puentes
para frenar esa ofensiva rusa pero que
sin embargo todavía mantiene una
posición muy dominante en la ciudad
ciertamente son muchas las versiones que
existen alrededor desde la toma de
bakmuz y por eso vamos a recuperar
también las palabras del jefe del grupo
de mercenarios Wagner denunciando la
falta de municiones proporcionadas por
Rusia como un factor clave para mantener
o no el control de esta región
endoniesca esto entre otros Muchos
medios lo Recoge al jazira sí Ángela
vamos a poner un poco en contexto que
esto significa que las tensiones están
latentes entre el grupo de mercenarios
Wagner y el propio gobierno ruso No
porque si finalmente Rusia se hace con
bajo mod esto se venderá como un triunfo
claro por parte del kremlin y el grupo
Wagner quiere reclamar también su papel
en esta batalla como decíamos en los
noticieros pues este fin de semana el
jefe del grupo Wagner lleve gojin dijo
que si Rusia deja de suministrar
municiones al grupo Wagner no solo va a
caer el frente en mahmud sino que caería
todo el frente en la región de no que es
uno de los objetivos principales del
kremlin en esta ofensiva militar una
cita textual del jefe del grupo dice que
si Wagner se retira de básmuta ahora
todo el frente colapsará la situación no
será agradable para todas las
formaciones militares que protegen los
intereses rusos como decíamos antes pues
se llegó a decir si esto formaba parte
de una burocracia o si realmente una
traición del kremlin y el comandante de
las tropas ucranianas en paralelo
refleja este artículo de allassira dice
que la situación en bahamut es
desastrosa para las tropas ucranianas
pero que todavía resisten
bien vamos a terminar precisamente con
un reportaje de New York Times que
refleja que pese a estas continuas
derrotas
en los últimos días desde el ejército
continúan resistiendo lo decía usted con
cada vez más dificultades Así es Y esto
es un reportaje del New York Times de
este propio fin de semana en el terreno
que dice que los soldados ucranianos han
atacado a bahmud tanto por suelo como
desde las colinas colindantes de basmud
y a sus alrededores de la ciudad una de
las tropas rusas en el terreno dice
textualmente que tenemos suficientemente
fuerzas para expulsar al enemigo de la
ciudad pero depende de las tareas que
tenga el comando ya sea mantener la
ciudad o infligir las máximas pérdidas
al enemigo sostiene este artículo del
New York Times que la lucha en bahamut
ya no se trata solamente de propiamente
la ciudad sino una maratón de desgaste
entre los dos entre los dos ejércitos
enfrentados para ver quién puede
derrotar A quién desde Ucrania si están
utilizando cañones de artillería y
alineados también con las líneas del
frente en los árboles en residencias
privadas y en vehículos de camuflaje y
edificios se están disparando entre 80 y
120 proyectiles al día y en el último
mes según recoge este artículo del New
York Times se han lanzado 5.000
proyectiles según un comandante en el
terreno también desde el ejército
ucraniano Ángela denuncian falta de
munición y esto se está viendo pues que
al final las tropas ucranianas han
venido perdiendo pueblos y aldeas en
estos últimos meses y esto se podría
consumar al final de esta semana con la
toma definitiva de las tropas rusas de
la ciudad de pues no lo sabemos yo lo
que le puedo decir es que continuamos
con el seguimiento Muchas gracias a
usted Marta gracias Ángela